alright thanks for taking your lunch in
here to talk about web application
performance everyone's favorite
lunchtime conversation I know so I'm
genre vlo I'm a web developer working
for comcast right now out of
Philadelphia and as you can see in going
to be talking about web application
performance this talk is based on some
work I've done or the past year and a
half or so on a product known as x2
cloud TV it's currently in a market
trial and we're slowly rolling it out
across the country and specifically it's
about what we learned about measuring
performance data so provide some
background on the application if you're
in a comcast mark you may have heard of
x1 already this is the new set-top box
it's leaps and bounds better than the
other ones you've had and basically x2
is a design update to that first and
foremost and secondly involves storing
your DVR recordings in the cloud so this
has a couple of benefits one you get
additional space for your DVR recordings
and this also allows you to string or
DVR recordings to any device inside your
home be that a desktop laptop you know a
mobile phone tablet which is great you
can also stream live TV and on-demand
content so the idea was that we'd have a
consistent experience across all these
devices so we basically split the teams
up into the set-top box team iOS Android
and web and I was one of the developers
working on the web application for this
and such what we're doing is turning
your
browser into a TV and part of that
experience is you know you turn your TV
and video is always playing so because
of that requirement of kind of video
being first and foremost and always
playing we built it as a single page web
app we used backbone on the front end I
was a ruby on rails application talking
to a hypermedia API that all the
applications talked with but I'm going
to talk about really doesn't matter if
you're using backbone or any other
framework or even for just building a
website these rules will play apply
regardless also we consider that you
know your experience of watching TV is
you turn on the television and you know
boom video starts playing so obviously
you want this app to be fat just like TV
is fast so in our quest to make it fast
we asked ourselves a few questions I'm
going to cover in this talk so one what
do existing tools provide what data do
you care about head to go ahead and
gather that data and then once you have
that data with you ahead and do with it
now before we can fulfill a requirement
to just make your website fast you need
to know first how fast we're slow your
app or website currently is and a way to
consistently monitor those metrics so
that when you get a target that you're
shooting for you can know that as you're
doing different performance improvements
know that that's actually helping or
hurting performance all right so let's
take a look at some existing tools to
throw up with one that we use often is
webpagetest org this was originally
developed by AOL and they ended up open
sourcing it and Google is kind of taking
the reins on this and they've done an
excellent job provides a bunch of great
data and suggestions as well for what to
do with your website you have to see an
overall performance of the page on its
first load and then repeat view when
assets are cash to see what the time
differences are give you a nice
waterfall view you can usually see in
like your network tab of your
performance tools showing the detail and
the timing information connection view
shows you each individual TCP connection
so you can see how different browsers
shard those you get a nice PageSpeed
optimization
to basically tell you hey here's then
just can do to improve performance
somewhere to what why slow does it's
right there in your face but here's one
spot where kind of fall short a bit so I
assure you when our app is fully loaded
it does not look like this this is a
loading screen which I mean the best
loading screen is in the loading screen
but the fact matter is we do have one
and when I got that down as short as
possible and by default web page test
will be like okay the onload event fired
we see the pages play Lotus we're to say
this is the fully loaded spot that's not
really the case in our application any
other one that does load additional
stuff after the pages loaded there is a
way to fix this in some browsers and
I'll kind of get to that little bit
later but that's a hile overview of web
page test fan tomas is another tool will
use as a much cooler name and as you can
see it is a phantom j/s based web
performance metrics collector and a
monitoring tool and this is basically a
tool that you would want to use in your
continuous integration environment or
with each commit of your codebase you
deploy your code to some development
server and then run phantom us against
it and this will spit out a ridiculous
amount of performance metrics for you
it's very useful we run it with grunt
dev perf which I'd recommend you check
out as well that gives you a couple of
benefits one you know it's grunt so it's
pretty easy just run the command and it
goes ahead and runs it plus since
phantom mas gives you so much data it's
kind of nice to see a smaller chunk of
information that grunt def gives you
which is this little view this is
actually in a web browser but they have
it styled to be like a terminal they
gives you that overall kind of time to
first byte on thumb reading time various
other things there some file information
on the size number of requests and then
warnings and then this is broken down by
each time you run it can kind of see
these charts go up and down I'll give
you a quick glance over it what ours is
like if the video plays well for us okay
so again this is a ridiculous amount of
information I'll just touch on a few
things real quick so for one there's
smalls latency and biggest latency
that's the file with the smallest
latency and the largest for the response
times from the timing section there's
time to first CSS time to first j/s on
Dom ready time or things let's typically
take a look at HTML for the JavaScript
if you're not using JSON to catch like
jeaious console messages that's there
also there's any j/s errors it's going
to throw those as well those pop up in
the browser for the Dom there's a bunch
of different things around different
dumb queries you can see how many of
those you're doing and see if there's
some l have an impact on performance
because again you can see that basically
each one of these things that it marks
is for each individual time you run the
grunt task which is nice you can tie
this anything the changes to individual
commit cows and sizes you can see our
body size HTML size change CSS sais je s
is for using jQuery like most people you
can see the sizzle calls that are being
used and then again you get this nice
film strip but kind of stuff with that
same issue again where thinks it's done
loading but really not done loading and
then it spits out basically for all the
data that populates those charts up top
you get a list of all the files that
were the reasons why those numbers are
where they are at in those charts there
so I don't recommend checking that out
for sure that's a grunt dev perfect it's
very useful but also has its limitations
for one I am pretty much bet no one is
using phantom j/s to surf your website
so I mean it's obviously similar to
Chrome in many ways but again there's
differences there and also you want to
know about what our users actually doing
on your website it's what you really
want is rum and I'm not talking about
the booze I'm actually talking about
real user monitoring or this is also
called real user metrics real user
measurement the M is not important it's
the real user part that's important
and New Relic is a tool used for this
the response er here so I'm sure they
can do a better job than I can about
their whole suite but i'll touch on a
few things about how we leverage them
for one they can break up the page load
times by request queuing server time
network time Dom processing page
rendering time show you a little more
fine-grain view into what the
application is actually doing what the
browser is doing and again this is all
for stuff happening on your server with
real users which is the benefit you want
to see there they can instrument all of
your Ajax requests just kind of nice so
you can get performs dataran any other
page X requests in our case for the
loading screen we're loading in
additional data so it's nice to get
those metrics for that you end up with
these charts you can do for individual
Ajax requests to get break down those
different network times and they also
allow you to manually report page load
timing data so with that issue there
with the fully loaded not actually being
fully loaded you can get around that
with new relic by vehicles saying hey
your support in time where this is where
I want to say my app is actually loaded
and send it back to New Relic in them
when it builds as charts it can take
that into account so you get the real
actual full time for your app being
ready all right now that we discussed a
few existing tools let's talk about the
data you care about so we care about
real users and New Relic is useful for
that but you may not be using New Relic
n even if you are there's some pieces I
feel its kind of best to gather yourself
so you can get the raw data and really
you know munge it and get the debut one
out of it so let's talk about a feature
that both fans muscle New Relic rely on
instrumentation and that is aw three
spec w3c spec called navigation timing
and if you want to see what this day is
basically if you open up your favorite
developer console and type window dot
performance timing then you'll get this
which is basically a bunch of different
timestamps then mark the different parts
of your full application request and
from these it's just a bunch of numbers
there but if you look at the
illustration the spec it kind of gives
you a nice break down so you can take a
look at each individual times
amp and then chart it out so you've got
unloading the previous document if one
was open there's checking html5
application cache the DNS lookup TCP
handshake and then you get to be actual
request itself and the response coming
back from the server and then the
various Dom events happen to build at
the document the CSS object model that
kind of stuff and finally the onload
event fires so that's some really useful
stuff you can really get a good glimpse
into what each user experienced as far
as setting the first page to them kind
of step back at a wider level view you
can see that basically network latency
is the time from one that first app
cache that up happens to response coming
back from the server and then there's
that processing that happens between the
processing all the Dom information then
finally load event and then those
together along with some initial unload
stuff make up that full HTP request so
then you have all that data available to
you which is nice but of course we still
have this problem with fully loaded not
necessarily being fully loaded because
that's not going to be part of that
navigation timing interface so you need
to account for that loading screen time
and if we have a way to kind of mark
that loading screen time being done and
you can kind of grab that calculation
there for that point in time to see how
much long delays free is up so you can
produce that time and then once you
gather all that data can start to build
some nice charts like this one that kind
of show the breakdown of network latency
the processing time splash screen time
loading screen time for that kind of
things but you really can't have one
chart to be like this is my web app
performance because there's a lot of
things that could be affecting these and
you can't really represent them in one
graph so talk about a few of those so
for one the user authentication state so
I'm willing to bet that for the most
part if the user is signed in in your
web app there's going to be more stuff
going on than if user is not signed in
and then once they are signed in there
are different types of users like for
example in our application the user may
have a DVR that mean not the may just be
live streaming they may subscribe to
premium networks
HBO there could be a bunch of parental
controls they've configured and that's
going to affect you know what we need to
do as far as returning there are TV
listings good to them or the recordings
that they've set up and if the users not
signed in its past three also doing some
sort of a/b testing so you have unless
an accuser sadder than being you know
segments into different groups and those
could be seeing different experiences
and then getting different response
times and you really need to gather all
of that also the number of items
returned in this case I'm kind of
talking about so for us we're making
another request to get your recordings
when you load up the application so if
you have a DVR you could have three
things record you could have a hundred
things recorded you could have a
thousand things recorded and if you have
a thousand recording as I need to return
that to you that's be much slower than
if you only have two so it's important
that when you're instrumenting these a
dr. quest that you take into account
what is the actual contents of that
response you know how much is the number
of items affecting the response time for
that and one piece that may be a little
bit specific to us but basically then
when dealing with video or games at this
point is we have a flash Swift that we
drop in the page because videos so corn
essential to this product we tie the
authentication in with the video players
so basically as soon as you start
loading the page we drop this
authentication Swift that typically just
you know drop it does this thing real
quick and then it happens but that can
bleed into that loading screen time so
that's one of the thing that we like to
monitor is how long is take from the
time we drop that Swift to the point
where it says okay we've got all the
data we need and we can move forward
with the application taking a step
outside of our application here's an
example from gmail now in this case
gmail will slow at one point when these
three specific factors were true so it
had to be the user had the people widget
enabled they had to be viewing gmail on
the web and they had to open email with
a large number of participants so as you
can see that are basically if you're
just logging overall response times then
you would never know that there is this
segment of users that are being affected
by slowness and so we much more
difficult to kind of diagnose
performance issues if you're just doing
these overall views of here's my
response time so make sure you consider
what other unique factors in your
application may impact performance when
you're thinking about web performance
data alright so gathering the data so as
I said we basically need a way to mark
the point when the application is loaded
completely so that we know at that point
and when that users truly ready for any
interaction we need a way to mark that
essentially so how to do that so back in
the day we would do something like new
date good time get back a nice time
stamp heck no script 5.1 gave us date
now which is the easier way to get that
but now most modern browsers have an
easier solution and a better one
actually and that is high resolution
time which sounds awesome right who
doesn't love high resolution things so
what is that exactly so for one that
creates a dumb high-res timestamp you
can see this if you type window duh
performance now and call that method in
your console and that provides a time
with sub millisecond accuracy measured
relative from the navigation stark
attribute of the performance timing
interface so that's that first part in
that big w w3c graph there and it's also
not subject to system clock skew or
adjustments adjustments because it uses
a monotonically increasing clock so
let's dig a little bit into what that
actually means they're so here's a quick
example about Y sub milliseconds it's
nice I'm gonna write a quick function
that marks a point in time is a start
time then just multiplies the width and
height of the window to do a quick
calculation going to return the
difference of that run that and we get 0
so it's like you know that took no time
at all to happen if you write the same
function by use window dot performance
now and go through that those steps then
you get this extremely accurate time in
this case it was 0.012 blah blah blah
milliseconds the spec mentions that it
should be accurate to the thousandth of
a millisecond I've seen some
just be more accurate than that others
especially on windows are only accurate
to the millisecond but again you get the
benefit of the monotonic clock which may
be wondering what exactly that is which
I did my first heard about it so for
what that is I went to the person
actually reviewed the commit in chromium
and here's that explanation of what that
means so most systems run the daemon
which regularly synchronizes the time it
is common for the clock to be tweaked a
few milliseconds every 15 to 20 minutes
so at that rate about 1% of 10 second
intervals measured will be inaccurate so
now you kind of see the benefit of why
that monotonic clock is a nice thing to
have so now we've got this app writing
marked using this high resolution time
and now we know the actual load time of
the full application there's no math
needed the value of it is the low time
up to that point but if we want to kind
of figure out what is the actual loading
screen time we've got a problem because
load event end is measured in a
timestamp based on you know the epoch
back on january first 1970 and we've got
this operating mark which is you know
based off of zero point being a few
seconds ago so we can't even do any math
to figure out what is that loading time
there unless we go ahead and mark a load
event n spot using a high resolution
time stamp on the onload event fires and
then we can do math but it's kind of a
bummer that we need to actually go
through that and the w3c recognize this
and they're working on a new spec which
is navigation timing too and that
basically uses the high resolution time
for each of the timestamps in that
performance timeline with a couple
tweaks but it's still in the draft state
so you can't use this anywhere right now
unfortunately but there is something
else and that is user timing and this is
great for a couple of reasons one it
allows you to get high resolution
durations between not only a couple
manually set user marks but you can take
one of those use remarks and then do a
higher restoration between that and a
window performance timing interface and
that's really nice this also solved the
problem of the web page test issue with
a 911 your browser's fully when they
absolutely loaded this will solve that
problem for the browsers that support
so as far as browser support goes let's
talk about that so there's the
navigation Tommy's and pretty much all
browsers except for ie I'm sorry except
for Safari I add this in version 9 high
resolution time is was added to ie in
version 10 and Android recently added it
again safaris not in that party and user
Tommy has even less support fire fax has
an implemented yet I checked the bug
report this morning it's was basically
created in August of 2012 and no one's
picked it up yet so I can will write
some code for Firefox this would be
great respect to implement so this means
basically we need to do a bunch of marks
we need a user timing mark we need a
high resolution mark who need a
old-school timestamp mark follows
different points in time so basically if
you go ahead and you mark a page start
mark in the head of the document using
all three of those marks a load event
and when the onload event fires and then
app ready when the app is ready you kind
of break things up in these different
sections here so there's the the blue is
the browsers that support navigation
timing you get through the network
latency processing the loading screen
red is browsers that don't support
navigation timing you can completely do
like a smaller version of processing and
the full application and then you can be
something green as things can get with
any browser because it's it's basically
after the facts you can use either the
timestamps to do those calculations so
on cloud TV we do all this we mark we
set these marks we do these calculations
we also log the information about the
user we take the number of items
returned by certain a toast calls into
effect and we consider the browser as
well and we log on that data so I want
to go ahead and actually do that work I
first went to check github of course to
see if someone actually was doing that
so I can just use their work and besides
a user timing polyfill I'm I didn't
really find anything so that I decide
okay go ahead I'll do the work and today
actually I'm open sourcing the library
we did for this and the spirit of a
conference at the beach I call it surf
and turf so
so this is available right now from our
github page go to github.com / comcast
it's there it's also an NPM so if you do
npm install surf and / always one string
it's available there as well and this
will allow you to set all these
different marks it will also have a
concept of events which is a start and
end mark as well as additional data such
as you may want to log again the number
of items custom data points like if you
want to set is user authenticated it or
not and all that duration calculation is
built in there for you so it's going to
handle do you use your timing high
resolution time or not all for you so
real quickly I will go through analyzing
this data so I mean you've gone ahead
now you've got all the stuff on your
logs and filling it up with all this
data about performance what are you to
do with it so we build charts like this
one using splunk there are other tools
such as Kabana and gray log to that you
can use if you don't have splunk those
are open source now here the y-axis is
the response time the x-axis is the time
kind of by our but the thing may be
wondering is what are we actually
charting in this in this graph and the
one thing that may pop into your head is
average response time and I would argue
that you don't want to chart that or at
the very least you don't want that to be
your primary focus because average
response times are for average products
and you're obviously not building an
average product because you're here at
jas comp this is the best conference
you're building some of the best
products out there so when you think
about it if you say that your
application returns a response in under
second on average there doesn't sound
that great talking about averages you
wouldn't want your web host to be you
know up and running greatly you know
returning quick response on average you
want them to always be doing that and
users want that as well so as you should
focus on is the 99th percentile at a
minimum to pay on your level of traffic
you maybe want to go to 99.9 or 99.99
percentile for that and that way you get
to look at what are the vast majority of
your users experiencing if you look at
averages it's gonna start to mass that
data so we basically we take our 90
percentile and we plot this Ford all
different parts of our applications so
this is an example of
user comes in via the default which is
your recent recordings or the grid or if
they're not authenticated or turn pages
and we break that up by network latency
processing and spawn time for recordings
you can see that we're recordings lead
to large response time so we noticed
this from our charts it seems for us
that the number of channels does not
affect response time and let's say
you're kind of drive on the point that
99 percentile is useful this is our all
Swift which is again that piece of flesh
will be dropping the page and here's the
chart comparing that to the loading
screen response time for 99 percentile
you can see that these are pretty much
in line with each other's then we know
that okay the worst users are having
that experience because of this Swift so
we need to focus on that the 95
percentile that still looks good it
starts to kind of not be as clear as you
get down to the 50th percentile then an
average there's really no relationship
there so if you're just looking at
averages you're not going to notice that
this is in fact a big impact on the
application so to recap make sure you
measure first at the 99 percentile log
the network latency processing time and
full web page requests also like any
major a specific events with the details
that you need to determine information
and leverage those w3c performance API
is for that you can talk to me on
Twitter at John rave and once again
there's a link to the github repository
thank you
hmm